[Musique]
vous êtes
jeune et qu'on cause à défendre
la bille ou spams à régis titre
pis sa cheville ou ne dort jamais oui
[Musique]
le désorienter les yeux rivés qu'un peu
qu'une seule fois
c'est la seule façon de dernière ce que
tu dois être
ces besoins que quelques motifs leur
force puissante machine suite à jeddah
mais je connais la
[Musique]
le chemin
cela va faire bientôt deux ans que je
fais les théories sur youtube et j'avais
commencé avec star wars 7 qui m'avait
totalement lancé dedans et aujourd'hui
en fin 2010 est j'ai enfin des réponses
et surtout d'autres mystères à théoriser
ceci me montre que le temps avance et
que la chaîne grandi vous êtes
maintenant plus de trente mille et je
tiens à vous remercier d'être autant
star wars 8 à 10 visés la foule beaucoup
n'ont pas apprécié mais personnellement
je l' ai beaucoup aimé star wars semble
prendre une autre route de ce que nous
avons habituellement à voir et ils ont
raison le temps avance dans la saga et
nous ne sommes plus à l'époque de
l'empiré il faut évoluer et prendre
conscience de certaines choses
l'udc l'a très bien démontré je préfère
vous prévenir tout de suite je vais
évidemment spoil énormément le film si
je veux pouvoir traiter librement de
certains mystères donc vous êtes
prévenus enfin nous pouvons parler de
star wars 8
et voici un très gros trois théories
totalement personnelle que j'aimerais
vous proposez c'est parti
comment sont directement avec le plus
gros mystère de ce huitième opus la
fameuse mort de son nook le suprême ni
d'heure dans star wars 7 nous était
présenté comme quelqu'un de grand de
sage une sorte de grand seigneur sith
entre guillemets cependant en star wars
8 nous sommes face à un snob débordant
d'arrogance et d'orgueil
malgré sa semblable grandes puissances
et c'est justement ce qui le tuera snop
s'est fait avoir par kay lorraine et
c'est clairement la scène la plus
mystérieuse du film sa mort était la
dernière chose que j'aurais pu imaginer
dans star wars 8 et plusieurs cas sont
possibles pour ce dernier
je ne vous cache pas être totalement
désorientée par rapport à la mort du
suprême leader néanmoins essayant de
dégager quelque chose par rapport à ce
dernier
alors ce premier cas de figure nous
pourrions supposer que ce n'était qu'un
simple usurpateur que savons-nous
exactement sur stocks et bien pas grand
chose on sait qu'il est le leader du
premier ordre et le maître de kayes
lorraine c'est un nouveau personnage a
mené dans star wars 7
il est celui qui a perverti ben solo
vers le côté obscur mais nous n'en
savons pas plus
et c'est justement pour ça que ce cas de
figure fait surface après le mystère des
parents de ré snoeck était le personnage
à éclaircir dans cette saga
nombreuses ont été les théories faites à
son égard celle de dark plagueis était
la meilleure d'après moi mais est-ce
qu'on se serait pas finalement emballé
snoeck se vante de sa puissance de ne
pouvoir être trahie qu'il est le suprême
leader et nous avons le droit à un
quiproquo énorme jeu sans tourner ton ce
havre
il tue son véritable ennemi et paf
snoeck moeurs coupée en deux trahi par
son fidèle apprenti cas et lorraine
qu'il méprise et montre qu'il se servait
seulement de lui pour sa puissance mais
ne serait ce pas du simple bluff
il est vrai que ce ne semble très bien
maîtrisé le côté obscur cependant il est
fort possible que ce dernier ne soit pas
si grand qu'on pense au final comment
n'at-il pas pu sentir le sabre juste à
côté lui tourné voire même entendre
c'est assez étonnant
nous pouvons prendre l'exemple de
palpatine qui avant de se dévoiler en
dark sidious avait réussi à prendre le
pouvoir simplement par la police
ic en séduisant le peuple nos pourrait
être un grand politicien et rien de plus
il aurait comme dark sidious cédrika et
lorraine et utiliser ses pouvoirs pour
prendre le pouvoir justement en
défaisant les derniers jedi ainsi que
luc éliminant toute menace pour le
premier ordre
sa tenue est d'ailleurs étrangement
bizarre pour un grand adepte du côté
obscur et nous pourrions supposer que ce
n'était qu'un usurpateur qui l'aurait
bluffé tout le monde et nous et tendez
grand fan on aurait surestimé snow que
le suprême leader suite à son arrivée
dans la saga
cependant ce n'est qu'un simple cas de
figure parmi tant d'autres stocks
semblent d'ailleurs maîtriser la force
avec une aisance maximale un simple
geste du doigt permet de maîtriser ray
ainsi que cai lorraine paso donc au
deuxième cas de figure que j'aimerais
vous proposait néanmoins restons sur le
fait que ce nom ait été surestimé par
nous les fans
ce serait le cas de figure qui collerait
le plus avec la scène que nous a
proposée star wars 8 snow qui amènerait
devant kyle lorraine pour qu'il la tue
et termine donc sa formation de sites et
nous avons le droit à un monologue avec
les quiproquos snob dit qu'il ne peut
être trahi qu'il lit dans les pensées de
ben solo il sent son sabre tourner et se
fait tuer par cai lorraine et là nous le
voyons à la tête de snow qu ils semblent
surpris il n'en revient pas de s'être
fait avoir
j'ai bien analysé la scène étant le plus
gros mystère de star wars 8
alors justement est-ce que snk n'aurait
pas sous-estimer son jeune apprenti
le fait que cai lorraine face une double
action assez similaires comme tourner
les deux sabres en même temps aurait pu
permettre au second sabre de ne pas être
détectées par snk qui ne sentaient que
le sabre de kayes lorraine c'est tout à
fait possible ben aurait pu berner le
suprême leader mais vous allez me dire
que ce n'est pas possible que le
supprime leaders se fassent avoir par
cai lorraine
et bien justement je voulais amener
cette question cai lorraine serait en
fait beaucoup plus puissants que snk
pourquoi pas à tel point que le suprême
leader n'aurait même pas détecté le
retournement de kay lorraine à son égard
ils auraient sous-estimé son apprenti
qui au final serait le véritable grand
méchant et l'élu du côté obscur
dépassant son maître comme anakin
auparavant après tout disney semble
vouloir ramener key lorraine comme
en échange la fin du film même si c'est
mal interprété par les scénaristes
donc je ne sais pas trop mais ce que je
sais c'est qu'il reste un dernier cas de
figure celui que je crois le plus et le
plus probable à mes yeux un cas de
figure brut et indomptée quelque chose
de tout à fait exceptionnel
snow creux reviendra nous parlons tout
de même de snk du suprême leader du
premier ordre
il possède une maîtrise de la force
exceptionnelle et même si j'avoue que la
scène de sa mort ressemble énormément à
la fin de star wars 6 avec dark vador
qui trahit sidious et bien c'est
beaucoup trop facile pour être produits
dans star wars 8 sachant qu'un dernier
opus sortira en 2019
snow possède une longueur d'avancé sur
tout le monde depuis le début et depuis
star war z snoeck a tout prévu
il connaît qu'à et lorraine par coeur et
sait quoi faire pour le mettre en colère
et leur antre donc plus puissants comme
anakin dans le passé avec dark sidious
il savait que ray existerait pour
justement contre écailles lorraine
donc il sait comment fonctionne la force
comment elle marche il sait qu'un élu a
existé pour contrer le côté obscur et
lumineux et que si l'équilibré perturbé
quelqu'un serait envoyée pour justement
faire revenir les équilibres et si nous
revenons à la scène de sa mort le
quiproquo n'en serait pas du tout en
fait
snow précise qu'il sent le sabre de ben
tournée qu'il doit tuer son véritable
ennemi et snow kummer s'est tout de même
très étrange sachant que ce 9 depuis le
début du film et prisca et lorraine le
considérant comme moins que rien un
enfant avec un masque d'ailleurs
revenons à quelque chose qui exploite
encore plus mystère la mise en connexion
de ré et ben par sonic snow précise
qu'il a mis en connexion ray écailles
lorraine pour justement mieux attraper
ray et permettre à kayes lorraine de se
reformer
cependant vous trouvez pas ça
extrêmement maladroit de la part du
grand supreme leader de mettre en
relation jeunes apprentis coupée entre
le côté obscur et lumineux avec une
future jedi et bien c'est parce que ça
pourrait être justement prévu pourquoi
ce n'est qu'après avoir bien méprisé cas
et lorraine jusqu'à le faire douter de
sa place dans le côté obscur l'inclure
est-il dans la mission de ramener rey à
snow clan la convaincant qu'à lorraine
était beaucoup trop instable pour ça et
snow klaus avait d'ailleurs parlons-en
de cette connexion entre les deux
protagonistes
un détail très important et que kay
lorraine et ray sont de nouveau en
communication après la mort de snow que
c'est un détail troublant mais qui a son
importance et qui pourrait supposer le
fait que ce ne soit encore vivant nous
ne savons rien de ce nom justement mais
sa puissance est réel et n'oubliez pas
que ce dernier a une longueur d'avancé
sur tout le monde depuis le début il
sait quoi faire
ils ressentent où ils prévoient tout
c'est quand même un peu gros que ce
dernier meurt aussi rapidement sans en
savoir plus sur ce dernier s'était tout
de même le suprême leader ne pourrait
certainement revivre comme un dark
plagueis après tout ce ne pourrait être
qu'un pseudonyme comme avait partagé un
abonné ou bien s'est il changer de corps
le général ex pourrait certainement
servir à ça ce n'est que le considère
comme un roc et enragé lui servant juste
à guider les armes et peut-être
pourrait-il prendre possession de son
corps
snow qui semble réellement puissants et
nous cache certainement quelque chose
sa mort m'a énormément perturbé et je ne
saurais vraiment pas dire s'il est mort
ou non disney reste assez imprévisible
la preuve en est mais au fond de moi je
pencherai sur le fait que ce n'est les
savoirs pour justement accroître la
colère de kayes lorraine le rendre
définitivement du côté obscur et il
reviendra d'une certaine façon
après tout s'il a toujours une longueur
d'avancé sur tout le monde il doit très
bien savoir que l'apprenti sith essaiera
toujours de tuer son maître au bout d'un
moment
ou peut être que snow que serait le tout
premier djeddah et comme a si bien
expliqué lamy aeros f
je ne sais pas mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que ce mystère est loin d'être résolue
n'oubliez pas que ce ne sont que des
théories et que je n'affirme rien bref
longue vie aux suprêmes leader
pour cette seconde théorie je pense que
vous étiez sûr que j'allais en parler
mais qu'en est il de la dernière scène
de star wars 8
dans celle ci nous voyons les trois
enfants esclaves rencontré au préalable
parler du retour de luke skywalker
contre le premier ordre
cependant ces derniers se font
interrompre par leurs maîtres et la
caméra se concentre sur un enfant
précisément sauf que ce dernier semble
être une sorte d'hystérie reg
il attrape son balai avec la force rien
que ça et nous voyons qu'il possède une
bague de la résistance certainement
celle de rose qui lui donne à qui est
cette enfant
qu'est ce que cette scène veut nous
expliquer il faut savoir que ça wars 8
est une sorte de transition à star wars
9 et voire même pour le futur de la saga
star wars
cet enfant porte un nom d'amy vie blague
et c'est un réel mystère pour cette saga
star wars
ce film a eu huit nous explique bien
qu'il faut que ce soit la fin pour les
jedi
cependant cette scène montre tout le
contraire elle nous montre qu'un autre
jedi pourrait exister un jour ou l'autre
et si les montrer à la fin du film je
pense que ça pourrait être le cas
néanmoins cet enfant est trop jeune pour
entrer dans la résistance et n'a aucun
moyen d'y parvenir
je pense que nous ne le verrons même pas
dans le dernier opus de cette dernière
trilogie
cependant si certains ne savent pas
encore
disney veut exploiter star wars au
maximum et même si cette saga marque la
fin de l'épopée des skywalker
le géant disney a prévu une autre
trilogie suivante il est même dit que
cette saga ce traitera d'une histoire
plus lointaines avec d'autres
personnages loin des skywalker cet
enfant pourrait être l'un de ses
nouveaux personnages
maîtrisant la force on suivrait ses
épopées quand il sera adulte car d'ici
la prochaine trilogie je pense qu'il
aura bien grandi certains suspects ray
que tu es miri blague serait un futur
padawan de ré mais ray est encore trop
jeune dans la maîtrise de la force et
reste très solitaire mais si cet enfant
apprend à se servir de la force
l'équilibré serait une fois de plus
perturbé comme dirait snoeck un alter
ego serait créé par la force pour le
contrer donc un adversaire pour cet
enfant existera cela en est même sûr si
cette scène et présente ce n'est pas
pour rien et cet enfant pourrait
symboliser le futur de star wars un
easter egg de la saga 10
12 je ne vois pas d'autre solution en
tout cas tenir y blague nous montre que
la force sera toujours là peu importe
les agissements et que peut-être il
n'est pas le seul à savoir s'en servir
tout comme masse par exemple mais qui
n'est ni du côté obscur ni jedi enfin
cet enfant est d'ailleurs un esclave il
possède une vie misérable et c'est
utilisé déjà la force depuis son jeune
âge
cela ne vous rappellerait pas certaines
personnes loin de moi l'idée de le lier
à eux mais son histoire et cette mise en
scène symbolise toujours les futurs
grands jedi a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez mais l'histoire de cet
enfant est pour moi loin d'être terminée
[Musique]
le mystère le plus exploité de la saga
star wars 7 8 9
les parents de ré qui sont ils beaucoup
pensé à l'udc
obi wan en solo et j'en passe mais au
final il n'en est rien du moins d'après
ce que nous montre le film d'ailleurs
quelle information avons eu par ce long
métrage ray souffre du fait qu'elles ne
connaissent pas ses parents depuis son
plus jeune âge
c'est ce qu'ils attirent avare le trou
définit comme le côté obscur sur l'île
d'actos elle n'obtiendra aucune réponse
et face à la paroisse miroitante sera
dévoilé le simple reflet de ré ne
montrant en aucun cas ses parents seul
ray peut découvrir cette réponse et le
fait qu'elle ne s'ouvre pas côté obscur
pourrait justifier le fait que la
paroisse ne lui ait montré que son
reflet ce dernier commence bien portants
part montré deux silhouettes les deux se
réunissant pour montrer ré ré descend
donc bien de deux personnes d'après ce
qui est montré
mais la connaissance de ses parents
pourraient soulager réélu montrer sa
place lui dévoiler comme ça ne l'a
tirerait pas vers le côté obscur
au contraire c'est ce qu'a donc essayé
key lorraine nous avons eu le droit à la
scène où ce dernier essayait d'attirer
ray en lui disant qu'il connaissait ses
parents jusqu'à la poussée à le dire
d'elle même que c'étaient de simples
paysans poivrot je ne me souviens plus
du terme exact mais qu'ils étaient
personnes et enterrer dans une fosse
commune sur jack où il lui dit ça pour
la libérer de cette souffrance et
s'allier à elle qui reste fermé au côté
obscur
à cause de cette souffrance entre autres
au départ je ne mettais pas attardé plus
que ça sur ce passage je pensais que
disney vous l'êtes expédié cette info
pour qu'on arrête de théoriser là-dessus
arrêter d'imaginer que aurait descente
de quelqu'un d'important ou autres ray
semble même le savoir au fond
d'elle-même que ses parents ne sont
personne elle le dit d'elle même et
pourtant plusieurs détails m'interpelle
sur tout cela
il est vrai que réfute créé entre
guillemets pour contrer caille lawrence
nos claudie de lui même mais l'identité
de ses parents pourraient être tout
autre de ce qui nous a été dévoilé déjà
par le fait que cai lorraine aurait bien
pu lui dire ça pour l'attirer tout
simplement du côté obscur et s'allier à
elle comme il le souhaitait il sait que
ça la fait souffrir la soulager leur
aurait rendu plus docile arrange one le
côté obscur ensuite j'aimerais vous
rappeler là
dion de ré cette dernière est abandonnée
sur jack ou et nous voyons un vaisseau
partir celui qui l'a amenée ici
tout d'abord comment de simples boivre
aux paysans ou je ne sais quoi pourrait
posséder un vaisseau de cette envergure
ce n'est tout simplement impossible de
plus ce cas il aurait ne mentionne le
fait que ses parents sont enterrés dans
une fosse commune sur jack ou cependant
pourquoi serait-il retourner sur jack ou
le vaisseau abandonne clairement ray sur
la planète déserte et s'en va pourquoi
serait-il revenu incognito pour y mourir
sans revoir leur fille techniquement ce
n'est pas logique du tout hui tout ceci
provient de la vision d'auray à la base
cette vision provoqué par le sabre laser
d'anakin puis de l'udc lui même qu'il
aurait apparemment choisi d'après maze
avait posséderait donc forcément un lien
avec les skywalker peu importe le type
la vision nous a déjà prouvé son lien
avec son alter ego caille lorraine
visible dans huit
le mystère est donc loin d'être résolue
enfin pour conclure sur la théorie
j'aimerais vous partagez une réponse de
ryan johnson le réalisateur de star wars
8 provenant d'une interview concernant
les parents de ré pour moi c'était un
choix dramatique détail le réalisateur
simplement le fait qu'elles entendent ça
que le public entende ça aussi ce
contexte si la réponse avait été tes
parents tes l'importance voici ta place
dans l'histoire
ça aurait été la chose la plus facile à
entendre un vrai sentiment
d'épanouissement
elle se serait dit oh super donc voici
qui je suis c'est ça alors que la chose
la plus dure qu'elle pouvait entendre
c'était tu n'auras pas la réponse
et ça serait utilisée contre toi parquet
lorraine qui essaye de faire de toi son
allié tu devras trouvé la force en toi
de te connaître et de lui faire face
tu devras trouvé la force en toi de te
connaître et de lui faire face
le réalisateur dévoile bien le fait que
c'était une tentative de kayes lorraine
pour l'attirer vers le côté obscur
les parents de ré ne sont donc pas
encore dévoilé d'après ce que nous dit
dre
that her en même temps qu'elle intrigue
aurions-nous sens aussi dans l'épisode 9
sans compter snoeck cependant ce poste
nous dévoile autre chose d'après moi
comme je le disais la connaissance de
l'identité de ses parents faire
réellement souffrir ray sic et lorraine
avait dévoilé ceci cela aurait
simplement soulagé ray comme je le
disais et justement ce poste nous montre
que ce n'était pas seulement un coup de
bluff de kayes lorraine mais que
justement c'était une tentative pour
l'attirer
donc ce dernier semble posséder la
connaissance de la réelle identité des
parents de ré c'est ce que je ressens en
lisant ce poste et vous que pensez-vous
de star wars 8
quel mystère vous intrigue le plus dites
le moi en commentaire après deux ans à
faire des théories en commençant sur
star wars 7
je suis heureux d'avoir enfin des
réponses et me montre que le temps
avance que la chaîne avance et je tient
réellement à vous remercier du fond du
coeur de l'avancement de cette dernière
c'est une réelle passion que de tenir
cette chaîne qui se concrétise de jour
en jour alors merci et merci à ceux qui
laisseront bien évidemment un pouce
bleus et qui partageront la vidéo
c'était votre dévoué argot rock et que
le 'lion' heures soit avec vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]